Hey, this is Mark and I'm the CEO and
founder of Tongle. We've recently
launched a new UI and I hope you really
like it. We've tried to keep it clean
and leave room for some new capabilities
that we will be launching and some of
the stuff that we had but needed to
bring to the forefront and one of those
is public events. And that's what I want
to talk to you about today. Your Tongle
Me page does not show your calendar. It
shows the time that you've decided to
make yourself available for meetings.
But sometimes there is one specific
event that you may want to put public
for people to know that you're going
there. For example, you may be going to
a conference and you want people to know
that you're going to that conference. Or
you're traveling and you want people to
know in which city you're going to be
when you're traveling. And that's what
public events allows you to do. Let me
show you how that
works. This is my Tungle Me page. You
can see that you do not see my calendar.
You just see the times that I'm
available. But we've added here this
public timeline. And on this timeline,
you can see that there are some circles.
And so, if I mouse over some of these
circles, it says I'm going on a trip to
Toronto. This is Labor Day. Uh I'm going
to be going to the Roger Waters um
concert at the Bell Center. If I click
on that week and I scroll down, you can
see that that's when the Roger Waters
concert is going to be. So, it's
actually appearing in my calendar. Now,
note, it's not my entire calendar that's
appearing. it's that specific event. So,
let me show you how we actually do that.
So, I'll log into my account. And by the
way, I'm synced currently with Google
Calendar, but you can sync your calendar
with any calendar that you want. Now,
let me put in the right password
here. Okay. So, now I'm going to go to
the home view. And there you'll see that
I can see my entire calendar because I'm
logged into my account. So, I'm the only
one that can see that. Now, I'm going to
be in San Francisco.
um next week and I want people to know
that I'm going to be there. So, I'm
going to say publish this event and I
can add a note. Uh I'll be at the
Blackberry developer conference. By the
way, that's where I'm going to be. So,
if you're going to be there, let me
know. Now, I can decide to publish this
event. And you'll notice that the little
eye icon next to that event turned
green. And I can also decide to tweet it
and let everybody in my network know
about it. So now I've connected it to my
Facebook and my Twitter and I can change
a message here if I want and then
publish it. In this case, I don't really
want to tweet it out saying that I'm
going to be at the conference. So you
can see now that a circle has now been
added to my public timeline letting
people know that I'm going to be at the
conference. What does it look like on my
public profile? Well, let's go look. So,
you can see now that it it's added a an
event here that says I'm going to be in
San Francisco. And now everybody
visiting my Tungle Me page will know
that I'm there. I can decide to turn it
off by going back to the event, click on
the eye and say make the event private.
If I want an entire calendar to be shown
as public because I don't want for every
single detail for every single event to
make it public, um I can go to calendar
and contacts and I'm in the syncing
section and you can see I've synced
different uh calendars there. I can
decide to to make my Facebook um
calendar public and by doing that I just
click on
private and I change this to public. I
can save events and all my Facebook
events will now be public on my Tongle
meet page.